[Music]
i discovered that he was liking other
girls pictures on social media that were
inappropriate what does inappropriate
mean he needs been
showing off their goods he can do
whatever he wants to he has no right
none to stomp on your values
[Music]
what up how we doing this is john with
the dr john delony show
i hope you're doing well having fun
get some sleep
i don't know whatever you're doing
somersaults in the neighborhood i hope
you're having fun whatever it is you're
doing and if you're struggling we're
sitting here with you so the show's for
to walk alongside you if you want to be
on it
give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask
a-s-k
let's go straight to the phones today
let's go to amanda in new jersey what's
up amanda
hi john how are you i'm so good
you're the most joyful voice i've heard
in a long time mostly because i listened
to kelly and it was good to talk to you
you're a joyful voice too kelly it's
just at a lower octave and a little bit
meaner but it's still joyful still
joyful
okay hey amanda what are you doing how's
it going oh it's going great thanks i'm
having a great wednesday so far
excellent excellent all right so what's
up and how can i help tell what's going
on
so my boyfriend and i have been dating
for about six months now and a few
months ago i discovered that he was
liking other girls pictures on social
media that were inappropriate
what is it
what does inappropriate mean
um inappropriate like um
they were in maybe like skimpy underwear
um
showing off their goods
showing off the goods
all right awesome
um so i confronted him about it and he
reassured me that he loved me and that
he would stop doing it um so fast
forward a few weeks after that and i
discovered that he was back at it with
liking these girls pictures
my question is
am i being a jealous girlfriend or are
there red flags that i'm probably
overlooking
okay so let me
what do you think
or what do you feel
so
i love him he's the first man i've loved
um and i can see myself with him but
this is
to me it just makes me uncomfortable and
a little bit hurt that he's still doing
it yeah um
what about
um
what about your
feelings towards this situation
what about your feelings have forced you
something about you have a feeling about
this you have a response to this and you
immediately roll it into well maybe me
it's probably me
i am probably feeling this way or maybe
i'm overreacting what makes you think
so little of the way you feel about
something
um
so
maybe because this probably goes back to
when i was a kid but
i've grown up like my feelings have
always been kind of like invalidated uh
um okay i've been known like oh jasmine
you're just overthinking you're you're
making this a bigger deal than what it
is so into adulthood i think i've
carried that with me and i'm just like
oh maybe i'm just making a big deal
about this maybe i should just
just let him have his fun and just
just sit back check out other people's
their goods
yeah right
okay so the fact that you've now
tethered
that connection
now because that
finding that
pulling that string right from
now people have always told me that i
overreact that i'm being a baby or i'm a
whiner or whatever they've always told
me that
to now that usually takes months or some
weeks sometimes months to uncover that
that road map right you've got it yeah
now your task is to no longer go mining
in the past
but to begin to practice
trusting yourself moving forward
okay okay so here's what i would tell
you it's very very hard it's very hard
because you've been told that your steps
don't count you need to get in line
behind somebody else
and so
that feeling of jealousy especially when
you're dating is um
it's a it's a signal it's your body
telling you something and i always think
it's super wise to stop and ask like why
am i reacting this way
and
here's
the way i read it and the internets are
going to say mean things about me that's
fine here's what they're going to uh so
before the internet starts whining he
can do whatever he wants to he can
follow whoever he wants to in imaginary
land on social media that's not real but
he likes to think it is um he can
like any picture he wants to and the
women making these photos can do
whatever they want to
that's i've heard that many times they
can do whatever they want right that's
fine
he has no right
none zero
to stomp on your values
or on your wishes or on the things that
make you feel uncomfortable in the
relationship and what you did was the
right thing
you went to him with your values and
your discomfort and you said this
particular action
makes me feel less than
it makes me feel
not enough
and i don't care if it was the way he
mowed your yard
i don't care if it was his views on
political issues i don't care what the
thing is
you were courageous and you went to him
and said
when you follow these other women
wearing hardly anything
and they are putting sexually explicit
material out there and you're into that
it makes me feel less than so i'm asking
you as your significant other to stop
and he said i'm in
you got it and then he lied to you and
went back
yeah
then
you are well within your rights to say
i'm uncomfortable with this relationship
and this is this to me the first time
it's about the discomfort thing
now it's about the lack of integrity and
his his
disregard for your values
if he feels like
this is an affront to my values i think
i should be able to look at people on
the internet who freaking cares it's
fine
then a person would with integrity would
have come back to his
girlfriend or his wife
and said
hey
i stopped doing this for a few weeks a
few months
and i'm troubled by this and here's why
i feel like you're acting like my mom i
feel like you are being unreasonable i
feel like this is just like play fantasy
but you are my real person like have
some sort of excuse some sort of
discussion
but don't just blow you off
okay okay
yeah you deserve to not be blown off
and you deserve to have have your values
recognized
and so if i'm you here's how this is i'm
just throwing something out there okay
okay i would circle back and say um this
happened again
do you want to be with me because i was
pretty clear about this makes me
uncomfortable
and
you're going
anytime we lay a boundary down
people run up and smash into it to see
if it holds
and he might say no i'm i mean if this
is that big of a deal to you we're
probably not going to work out and if
that happens you have to hear me say
this it was never going to work out
it might just fall apart five years from
now with two kids
yeah that's what i'm scared about
exactly yes and it's again it's not
about
hitting the little heart thing on
some woman in her underwear on social
media
it's about you
being so courageous to state your values
and him being like i don't really care
i'm gonna do whatever i want to and i
love you oh i love you but i'm gonna do
whatever i want to and you start when
you get those two competing messages you
feel crazy right because you're in the
gap yeah you feel nuts like he says he
loves me and i love him
but he but he's doing these other things
so if i'm you i would ask that question
if the answer is yes of course
then i would say then for 60 days for
two months i want you to delete all
social media
i want to i want i want you to show me
that i'm more important than a fantasy
world a not real world
and i put the stakes pretty high
that's just what i would do you don't
have to do that okay
okay
okay that's that'll be hard but i will
definitely definitely try it how old are
you amanda
i'm 27.
are you settling
i
think deep down inside i maybe okay
that's hard for me to admit no i know i
know i know and this isn't and by the
way this isn't because
he looks at people in their
like sexy pictures online that's not
that's not it just because somebody does
that doesn't mean somebody's settling
right
yeah
but my guess is there's deeper value
things here that you are slowly
wallpapering over
for the sake of this relationship slash
for the sake of this guy
oh boy okay
am i right
yeah you're you're right
i think i was just pushing it back and
out
kind of masking it was just like oh
you're just
like maybe just see how this plays out
but
yeah you're you're right
it's always it's it's almost never about
well i don't say that
i usually don't look at behavior first
because people say and do dumb things
that's just life and i am first in line
there i say and do dumb things
but i always want to roll back to
people's values
and
after i say hey here's a value for me
um does somebody else meet that value
when my wife says hey
i can't be a part of this
then i have to hear and meet her value
or i've got to leave
you know what i mean because values are
hard they're in stone and
for whatever it's worth amanda don't
settle
okay okay
okay i'm trying not to cry but you're
you're right you're welcome to cry but
i'm not i
you've known this for a while right
yeah
yeah i think i just pushed it to the
side yeah because it feels good to have
somebody with you right
yeah it feels so good
and holding hands is good and making out
is good and laughter and joy is good
having someone to do things with is good
but man having somebody walk all over
the things that you think are important
to who you are and who you want to be
are not good
yes very true and i've seen it happen
with
my parents um my dad has
always he hasn't been faithful to my mom
throughout the year so
my biggest fear was always ending up in
the same situation as my mom i guess
yeah
so can i can i give you one
nugget of wisdom that i want
you to put in your backpack okay yes
actually tattoo this one on your forearm
okay the way to break that cycle and it
does become a cycle
what we normally do to try to fix that
cycle is we try to be better for other
people
okay
so i'm imagining that you watched your
dad be unfaithful and there's all kinds
of stories about why that happened and
the reasons behind that etc
a logical path forward is i'm gonna be
the best girlfriend wife ever
i'm gonna be so good
that that can never happen
and it's when people realize that most
of the time
infidelity
is because the person who is
not faithful doesn't like who they are
it's not because of the other person
so the greatest gift you can provide in
your relationship moving forward any
relationship you're a part of is that
you don't seek to make sure everybody
else sees you as great
but that from the inside out you heal
and realize i'm who i freaking am
because i'm amanda from new jersey
right
yes it's you healing from the inside out
and there's something radiant about that
is there something so highly magnetic
about people who are whole from the
inside out
it's just like so true it's it's
incredible you're you've met them before
you've seen them and you talk to them
you're like oh what is that
it's just like they are at peace with
who they are
they're at peace with who they are
and it's it's just
so i'm not telling you to break up with
this guy you do what you're going to do
i'm telling you that you are worth more
than having somebody spit on your values
you're worth more than trying to become
something so that somebody will be
faithful to you
they will love you
[Music]
that becomes performative and at some
point the lights go out in the theater
and the curtain closes and the
performance ends
and that's when you find out who you
really are
and that person amanda is worth being
loved
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change save yourself the headache and
call churchill mortgage today at triple
eight loan 200. trust me that's triple
eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer nmls
consumeraccess.org equal housing lender
1749 mallory lane suite 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we are back um
we're gonna go to mark in um idaho falls
um it's important as we're um
mark you there
yeah i'm here hey man so i'm gonna set
the stage here
recently had your wife andy on the show
and correct um
she talked about working through
um
the discovery that uh the father of um
somebody close to you
had sexually assaulted and sexually
abused your
young teenage daughter
and one of the
she was 11 at the time she's 11th time
okay
oh man so one of the
one of the things when we were talking
she mentioned was that her husband uh
you was really
struggling with rage
and i don't know if you remember the
call if you listen to it i don't know if
it's out yet um
but
i am the daughter i mean i'm the father
of a 12 year old and a six-year-old
little girl
and i felt my body
reacting to that call and i said man if
you have your have your husband call me
and here you are man you're a brave
brave man
um so just starting out of the gate i
want to thank you for calling and um
let's work this one together man so tell
me what's going on
well i'll do my best to try to contain
my crap um hey this is
a we've got great editors on this show
and b
i'm
by far the most full crap person here so
you let it run man
well some some other things have come to
light since
my wife had spoken with you but i guess
my question is
and i i had to write it down um you're
trying to just contain emotions and
stuff but how do i a loving father of
five amazing daughters handle my hatred
and rage
towards this evil person yeah and at the
same time try to keep my composure
and put on a happy face for my family
um
yeah that's kind of where i'm struggling
and then to
kind of add more to it so my my daughter
that we've found this out about
um you know
she's been in counseling and everything
else but very recently um
we found out that she is being
victimized online by other men who are
sending her videos and
and what have you i've since been taking
control of of it all but this just adds
to my anger into my hatred
um
you know i'm i'm
in front of my family i'm pretty calm
and collective and and i i hold my stuff
together pretty well but when
i find myself just kind of alone my uh
my mind tends to wander and
and the rage and hatred and anger come
out very very quickly um
i'm a pretty active guy i'm involved
heavily with jiu jitsu and mixed martial
arts and
and other physical things and it seems
like those kind of curb
um the anger although i do feel sorry
for some of my my counterparts that i i
do these things on but i find myself
just kind of in the recesses of myself i
it's very very close to the surface and
if any time i even bring up just
slightly
this stuff it just it the hatred anger
just overtake me yeah
yeah
and i think any
any mother any father listening to this
um i would say especially the fathers
just because i am one
i mean i i can't imagine somebody
experiencing what you're experiencing
and have experienced and not feeling the
exact same way um i'll tell you this is
the single hardest call
i've ever had to make
i've ever been a part of all the calls
about violence all the calls about this
is the hardest one and jenna and kelly
let me know this one was coming
and
like you i actually made some notes too
um
because i'm gonna get emotional okay
so i want you to think less about like
i'm some guy with all the answers as and
more than
um i'm a fellow mixed martial arts guy
too and we're just a couple of dads
sitting down trying to figure out what
happens next okay yeah is that cool
so i want you to interrupt me and stop
me at any time because i can get to
preaching a little bit um and tell me if
i'm out of bounds ever okay
okay
i'm also gonna promise as hard as it is
i'm gonna tell you the truth is that
cool
yeah
and if at any point you get pissed off
at me that is completely okay all right
first thing here is your anger and your
rage are right
it's your body responding to the deepest
and most primal
violation that i can imagine
okay
so i don't want you to think that you're
crazy or that you're nuts or something's
broken inside of you it is not
okay
can you tell me about the rage
um how does it come over you
it's just i guess
kind of like a tsunami where i get these
moments where
just randomly and i guess i could kind
of liken it a little bit to what i would
imagine like ptsd would feel like to a
certain extent where
i'll just be driving to work or in a
store or it tends to be kind of when i'm
by myself and i have my thoughts to
myself and it just kind of overcomes me
where
i just feel this just rage and that's
probably the best word for it where
you know i haven't done anything to this
individual i've made promises not to um
is this person in jail
no so uh
last we're aware of it's all under a
investigation okay and they can't share
anything else with me at this point um
it sounds like maybe some other victims
maybe have come through which is almost
always
my daughter because my daughter does not
want to be the first person to
talk or do a forensic interview or any
of that
um
i think what
bothers me probably just as much too is
you know i have a bit of a law
enforcement background as well so i know
how long these proceedings can
take
um and so to kind of answer your
question it just it seems like
when i'm by myself and just kind of
loaned to my thoughts i just
i fantasize about hurting this person
like i
i want to
i want to see this person's world just
burn
and i want to see his family watch it
burn in front of him yep
because that's what he did to me
i want to be there to see it and smile
smiling
i've never hated someone so much and so
bad of course as i do this individual
and for
legal sakes and everything else i feel
like i can't do anything about it
i can't do anything not for legal sakes
we'll get down
because what
because then my family loses me there
you go
that's right
so this is beyond anger and this rage
the the word i usually associate with
rage is trapped
and you just explained it perfectly
you your body is saying do this thing
and the fantasies the pictures you're
creating in your head about what this
thing would feel like and look like and
be like
is powerful
and also there's the reality
you've kept up with the cane velasquez
thing probably like
you see the other side of that
yeah and
i know i know this doesn't make logical
sense as well but there is so much guilt
that i feel because i'm the one that
dropped my daughter off hold on hold on
that's it that's it that's it
you're not trapped in this rage cycle my
brother you're trapped in shame
because you feel like this happened on
your watch
and you feel like you should have been
able to do something to protect your
precious little girl and you're trapped
in an imaginary failure
and you may have even had some feelings
that this dude was a scumbag you may
have even felt that
or you're you know maybe not maybe not
but there's always that like uh there
was there was a prompting i i felt like
there was a prompting about this guy
that's right you and so
now what you've done is you're trapped
in these recurring thoughts and you wake
up and the adrenaline and the cortisol
that you have harnessed over years of
law enforcement stuff and jiu-jitsu
training you know what happens next and
you know that and your body's primed for
it and
you keep looping back as though you can
go back and edit what has happened
and here's the worst thing i can tell
you
it happened and there's a period at the
end of that sentence
there is not a single thing you can do
to stop what happened
from happening
because it already happened
and until you grieve the absolute bloody
hell out of that
your body will continue to piece up and
piece up and spin up and ready to roll
and get ready to roll over and over and
over again to try to solve a problem
that can't be solved backwards
and i'm telling you this as a guy who's
got a very similar background to you
who's got a little girl
and i told kelly the reason this call
was going to be hard for me because i'm
telling you things that i wouldn't want
to hear
right
yeah
and when we get trapped and we get
enraged
the switch that gets flipped
is our ego
becomes about revenge about getting even
and you are chugging poison every day
and you're spraying it across your
family like a lawn fertilizer spreader
and you're hoping that dude will die and
he will not
just you
so let me tell you this as
directly as i can
this man stole from your daughter
and he stole from your family and he
stole from future generations
but if you allow your rage and anger to
pulse through your veins creating
distance between you and your wife and
your daughters and your community then
you are voluntarily handing this man
everything these girls have left
don't do that
is that fair
yeah do not give him this
he's taken enough
your anger and rage is not about her and
it's not about him it's about you and
you my brother have to forgive you this
is not your fault
like i said i
i know logically that makes sense
but
you have to say the words i forgive you
mark
i don't know if i'm there yet i know
but you got to
and
again i'm piling it up on you now
but you think you're covering it up at
home
my guess is you're a nuclear reactor
because what's happening now is your
daughter has become a project she's
become somebody to heal someone
something to solve something to get
better she's become a picture in a frame
right a cause to take to the streets for
and what she really needs is to be your
daughter
okay
and you are a nuclear reactor right now
and so you're good enough and you're
disciplined enough
you've worked your ass off to become
super disciplined so that you can
control yourself in hard moments
but the inside of you is on fire and
children are particularly attuned to
that that electricity
and so this is the hardest thing i'm
i mean the second hardest thing i'm
gonna tell you
you've gotta decide i'm gonna set this
thing down
and i wish it was harder than that
and i wish it was more complex than that
but you have to make a series of
behavioral choices to stop this
yeah because the rage is gonna kill you
and the rage is gonna take
these five beautiful wonderful daughters
daddy from them
and there's a reason why when this
happens often it breaks up families
because somebody's not grieving enough
somebody's grieving too much somebody's
too angry someone's not angry enough
this will blow your marriage up if
you're not careful
yeah
yeah it's already caused some amount of
stress yeah it has and hey all that's
normal man that's totally normal
y'all aren't crazy you're not busted up
i mean this is a mess and the the awful
part about this is it will ricochet
through right once that switch is
flipped and once that darkness is open
especially in a pre-bet pubescent teen
entering into being a teenager
um
yeah man it's a rabbit hole now you just
found
down the rabbit hole even further right
yeah
this thing will have consequences and
cascades throughout
and it's a decision a daily decision to
handle and deal with and work through
and heal those things as they happen
and not
like every time every time like
especially recently as i've taken away
my daughter's phone and seen some of the
conversations of some of the pictures
that people have sent her online
it's enraged it brings everything so
close to the surface again that it just
i we live it over and over and over
again and in this sense and in a way to
try to protect
my wife too i she's aware of these but
i refuse to let her see any of these
vivid images
that i've had to see and endure over the
last couple of days right
is it does it benefit you
to see that stuff
no but it's too late i've already seen
it i know
but now you've got you've got a choice
moving into the future
when someone says we've seen we found
some things on your daughter's computer
at school or we have found some things
on a friend's computer
you now know
um
i don't need to see that tell me what it
is
i'm good
and can i tell you this we often um when
things happen to our kids
our brain replays those things as though
they are happening again in real time
okay so conversation we have with folks
who
lose a child in a car wreck
is one of the one of the keys to healing
is recognizing
that kid experienced a moment of terror
or maybe a moment of intense pain
as the car wreck happened
but now that kid is not
you see what i'm saying
yeah
and
your daughter experienced some dark dark
evil
fear
terror paralyzed
and right now she's safe in your home
and she's got a mom and a dad who love
her
see what i'm saying she's still hurting
and she's still hurt and she's got
healing to go
but it's so easy to go back to she's
still on that in that moment and she's
not right now
okay
yeah
i will tell you as a guy who tries to
out weight lift and out shoot and out
run and out train and out learn new
things my
hurts
the only way through this is grief
[Music]
yeah i feel like i can't outrun this you
cannot i promise you you can't you will
make yourself insane and you will end up
with a heart attack or a stroke
um and or kids who are nervous to be
around you
or you can grieve it and that's the
dropping of your shoulders
and that's the screaming and being raged
out of god and being angry at what
happened and how slow the system is
[Music]
and when those thoughts lightning bolt
into your head which they do and quite
honestly brother they will they're going
to
that's the moment
right when that thought comes into your
head the picture of that guy
the thought of that door slowly opening
in the dark and you see that crack and
you see that shadow of that guy standing
there because i know you've imagined it
when that goes into your head instantly
you can't help it when it does
that's when you've got a choice i will
not meditate on this
and the key is not just shutting that
thing down but it's having another
picture to replace it with
and so i would have pictures of my
daughter that make me laugh pictures
with my family that bring me joy
memories of times when we whatever and
i'm going to make a conscious decision
every
single
time that when that thought pops into my
head i'm gonna say the word out loud
nope
and i'm gonna have something else to
think on that brings me joy
and here's what's gonna happen over time
your brain is going to recognize this is
neuroscience that you my friend are
driving now
it doesn't have to default to the
automatic survival setting because you
are back in control
and it will dial down
the rage
right now it feels like that rage is
keeping you and your family safe and it
is not it's drowning everybody
what will keep your family safe is a dad
who is fully present
who's not at peace with what happened
but is at peace with what comes next
okay
you also cannot do this by yourself and
you may
it may be that you're in a situation
where traditional counseling might not
be your thing
do you have a group of guys that you
trust and can go get nachos and a beer
with and just be honest
that's kind of
kind of struggling with that a little
bit because historically speaking i've
had my church friends i've had my mma
and jiu jitsu friends i've had my law
enforcement friends my ems friends and
they typically don't interact or mingle
with each other i like to keep things
almost separate
mark stop trying to control everything
it doesn't work man it doesn't work
yeah
yeah
okay
you got kicked in the teeth hard man you
lost a bunch of teeth
and so now the question is what you can
do next you're gonna go back to the gym
you're gonna say hey i'm not fighting
anymore it's fine
what am i gonna do um but i think
calling a group of guys and getting them
together
and just saying hey this happened
and i'm just sick about it i just need
to tell a group of guys that i love
yeah it's the word that nobody wants to
hear nobody wants to use especially
tough guys
um like you and i but you gotta have to
be vulnerable you gotta roll over and
say i got hurt
and somebody hurt my most prized
possession
gonna have to say that out loud to other
people
and that's part of the healing process i
wish i knew how to give you a pill to
make that not the case but that is the
case
on the other side of grief
and on the other side you'll still get
mad mad mad you will get angry angry
angry
the difference will be that you won't
feel trapped
and your body won't be enraged
you'll be mad and pissed off like you
should be
and he won't get the sentence that you
think he should unless some people come
forward i'll also challenge you the same
way i challenged her your 13 year old
doesn't get very many votes in this one
yeah okay and i know that that's hard
and i know that's quote unquote not cool
and you're gonna feel like you're
re-traumatizing her whatever right now
she needs parents who a believer and b
are willing to say
i know this is what you think you want
but you're a child and we're going to be
in your corner
yeah okay
and that's super hard
have you heard my analogy about the
twin towers
no
so
i heard it from uh
one of my favorite therapists who was
talking about
rebuilding a marriage after infidelity
and here's and it works across the board
so i'll give it to you
with the understanding that the greatest
gift you could give your children right
now all five of them
is to heal your marriage
and to heal and to grieve
by yourself and together okay
um
she said that
you could never go back to
downtown new york
and sweep up all the steel and ash and
dust and broken glass and use all of
that to re those materials to rebuild
the twin towers
they have fallen
the only choices you have are to a walk
away
and leave it in rubble
or
hire a couple of contractors get some
construction crews down there and
excavate the entire site
and then go sit with some architects and
some engineers and some artists and
reimagine and rebuild something arguably
more beautiful
structurally stronger
that's a monument to the past but is
also a
clear directive for what comes next
and so we're not trying to get back to
what was we are trying to build
something that will be
and you what that looks like in real
life is you and your wife go take a half
day retreat or you all get out of town
and you for the first time weep
not from a place of anger or rage or
control but from a place of grief
and you'll write letters to eat all five
of your daughters you dream about what
could be
where you all want to live what you want
to do all of those things you talk about
what you need and what she needs from
you and what you need from her
and y'all recommit to
practicing the things every day
see what i'm saying we're rebuilding the
whole thing from the floor up this is
just what happened this is where we are
the towers fell yeah
a lot of wasted energy and a lot of
wasted anger and rage are in trying to
preserve what was what was is no more
this happened
can i tell you this
what's up
um
your daughter is
lucky he's all bloody hell that she has
you as her old man
and i'm telling you that after talking
to thousands of dad over the last two
dads or last two decades
won the absolute lottery getting you
and it's time for you to understand and
believe that
you're a good man mark
you're a good dad
thanks
okay my commitment to you is i'll be
with you every step of the way call
anytime
do i have your commitment that you're
not gonna do something stupid you're not
gonna hurt anybody
yeah i'm not gonna do anything okay as
much as i want to but i know the one
thing i want you to commit to doing is
not committing to trying to fight back
the rage moving forward i want your
commitment to be i'm gonna heal
and i'm gonna grieve like crazy
and then my wife and i are gonna
re-imagine what comes next and then
we're going to be about building that
with our five daughters and that my
friend is
shapeshifter generational
changer family tree kind of stuff and by
the way
um at some point on the back end of
grief
there's making meaning of this madness
and making meaning might look like you
rejoin the police force and join a task
force or you create a group of dads and
fathers or you go to the school board
and you get computers and screens out of
there because these kids are being
handed weapons of mass destruction and
they don't even know it
that you petition your local whatever
county to increase
the
you know penalties for fill in the blank
you run for public off i don't care what
it is but at some point
after you grieve this and you're able to
breathe and you're able to relax and you
be able to control the dial those
thoughts you take control of those
thoughts
you begin to say okay what are we going
to do next
how we've now found ourselves way into
the into the jungle
we've hacked our own path through here
how are we going to invite people to
walk on this path with us now
i love you man and i'm grateful for you
and
one of the strongest bravest men i've
talked to in a long long long time
and thank you for being honest with us
man and i'll keep walking alongside you
we'll be right back
hey what's up daloni here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
delony that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
deloney
all right we are back let's go to
my home state of texas and talk to renee
what's up renee
hey dr john how we doing
doing pretty good how are you we are
just
we're getting through this one today man
it's been a tough one yeah
that was a rough call that was hard man
hard hard hard stuff what are you up to
oh man dr john so the reason i'm calling
i'm just
i am so just like at a point where like
i need to make some decisions but
um
well
so my parents they're like really
they're very an old-fashioned
traditional i'll get into some backstory
later but i've been uh dating my
boyfriend for almost four years now and
um
he's he's great this is
the best relationship i've ever
been in and um
you know he's awesome he's great
my sisters have met like my sister has
met him
my friends have met him but i have not
told or introduced him to my parents
does he have seven arms
or is he like
is he
like uh
i don't know
why are you hiding him
well one is just because kind of listen
look at you you come out swinging hey
hold on now
why why are you hiding him like why are
you hiding them
well we have a 21-year age gap okay how
old are you
i'm 31.
dang what who cares
all right so you're 31 you're dating 100
year old so what
uh i know think how much fun you can
have he's almost retired already
i'm just being i'm telling you
renee i'm totally messing with you
like why are you hiding him
um i'm just really like just really
nervous like my parents are so like
they're the source of a lot of
anxiety
they've just been very
they're very old-fashioned i was i grew
up in a very strict
uh
religious household um
i mean like they were very very strict
like even up until my 20s there could be
borderline controlling and just do you
have a job now
yes i do okay it sounds like
and you and i could get into this for a
long time
it sounds like um
they still have a control over you
whether it's emotionally or
psychologically or spiritually of some
sort
like you're gonna have to let them go
they don't get a vote
doesn't
matter for some reason they still have a
powerful hold over you
you're 31 years old
you're a grown woman
and they don't get a vote
and what i'll tell you is just because
they don't get a vote doesn't mean
you're disrespectful and doesn't mean
that you don't love them
that means they no longer get to speak
into the actions and day-to-day
decisions of your life now if they're
good parents they're still gonna
complain and give you wisdom and be like
i wouldn't do that that's fine that's
what parents do yeah but they don't get
a vote
and you've been holding their voting
card for four years
and what's wild about that is that card
weighs about 10 000 pounds and you've
been dragging it around
that's true and you have
for some i mean not for some reason i
know why it's hard i'm making it sound
so simple
but
but you have dragged around a ten
thousand pound cinder block
called parents opinion
on boyfriend
for four years quit carrying it
or carrying it
right
right right they don't get a vote
if they choose to not love you
anymore because of who you love then
they've made a choice
and it will be hard and it'll be
heartbreaking and it'll be devastating
but it won't be as heavy as dragging
around a ten thousand pound
cinder block
okay and in some ways it will be freeing
and if they hold money over you they can
keep their inheritance
and if they hold well the christmas
present they can keep their christmas
presents
if they think so little of the daughter
they raised
that they are going to disassociate with
her over this then
you clearly know where you stand with
them right
right exactly now
if they give you their wisdom and
they're like we don't think this is a
good idea but we love you and support
you that's fine that's what parents do
if they say hey it's going to take us a
minute
right we get some time
and we have this conversation with kids
who come out i mean we have this
conversation with all all different
kinds of people parents do get a minute
i give them that like i had a picture
that i had of what christmas and
thanksgiving was gonna look like and
that picture's gonna be different now
one because you're bringing a senior
citizen home to i'm just kidding i can't
help it i can't help it
lots of people can't help it listen
you're my friend and i like to climb on
my friends
but like you know what i mean like it's
going to be different than the picture
they had that's a shock so be it it is
it is
um and i probably wouldn't just show up
and be like ta-da here's darren i
wouldn't probably do that
yeah for calling what how do i like
break this to him like
i mean i have an idea
it's not a breaking it
can i be real honest with you i've been
holding back a little bit can be super
honest yeah go ahead give it to me
straight you're ashamed of him
no yes you are
i am not ashamed of him you're ashamed
of him and you're ashamed of you
otherwise you would walk through
the middle of that front door and be
like this is who i am
and this is who i love
tell me i'm wrong
um i want i i definitely want to say
you're wrong i'm just really really
behavior's a language my friend
behavior's a language and what you are
telling me by how you act is it you love
this dude but you want to keep him
behind the curtain
because he's got old gray hair
and he probably still wears pleats on
his pants
no actually no
that's just how they rolled in the early
80s do what i mean my friends have met
him my sister has met him and he's met
pretty much everyone except them just i
know but you're talking about him like
he's a like he's a
like my my
wife has met my boss
my my wife i mean my my co-workers have
met my kids like you're talking about
him like he's a
a display
right he's a part of your life
and after four years quite frankly he's
a part of you y'all are together
right
right
so it's not like a big reveal
i mean it is
be honest at four years the reveal is
the deception
yeah exactly right and so
i i would honestly call my mom and dad
if you live down the street from him i'd
go visit him or
um otherwise i'd call them on the phone
and say hey here's the thing i've kept
this from y'all and that's on me but
i've been dating this dude for three and
a half four years and i love him and
he's awesome and he's a thousand years
old
and
i it is not traditional and it is what
it is you know what i mean
yeah and i wouldn't go into and if you
can't accept this but no let them be
grown-ups
and
maybe they'll surprise you
maybe they'll surprise you probably they
won't you know your parents pretty well
right
oh yeah yeah
and if they throw a fit you can say whoa
whoa whoa whoa i'm not asking
for your permission i'm not asking for
is this the right thing
i'm telling you this is the person i've
been with for four years
we'd like to come to dinner
you see what i'm saying i'm taking all
the air out of everything i'm not
walking in there with it with 25 filled
up balloons
right
i'm walking in there empty-handed and if
they choose to ask me to leave they just
ask me to leave if their behavior
chooses
it tells me that they don't want me
there then that's that's heartbreaking
and sad and i'll be
um
i'll have to grieve the the crap out of
that but i'm gonna leave right
because you don't get a vote this is who
i love
and it may come with consequences you
may lose your inheritance or lose the
ranch or whatever the thing is
right and then you've got choices to
make but
yeah
if you're not the one with the problem
with the relationship
do you have a problem with the
relationship
no not at all um
i don't have i have zero problems i mean
one of the reasons
i've been kind of
so
just really thinking about kind of how
well i need to tell them i need to tell
them because we are
ready we have made we've had
plenty of serious discussions about our
future and we're kind of ready to take
that next step but
what's the next step
we like to get married one day um but
obviously like neither of us wants to do
that without first obviously kind of
interacting and getting to know my folks
and all of that does he feel weird that
does he feel weird that you haven't
taken him home yet
yeah he definitely feels weird if i was
him i would i would i would be weirded
out i would think you're ashamed of me
when i was dating my wife i had real
long hair and it was dyed different
colors and i think i had five earrings
just i was had tattoo i was just an
idiot okay
and
when she was taking me home she said
look
this is good
you are not going to be like the other
people i've brought home
and i was in my 19 year old or 20 year
old indignation oh yeah this is just me
i was such a poser i was such an idiot
but
um here's the thing she said you got to
take all the earrings out
and i need you to comb your hair regular
like a normal person and
i really cared about her and so i did
and her family gave me a hard time as
they should have
and they're
so the most incredible in-laws you can
ever imagine
my fear is that for four years you've
you've just
demonstrated to this guy
that
um you have to hide him
right and my fear is for four years
you've communicated your parents i don't
trust you i can't trust you and that
might be well earned
and for four years you've treated him as
a museum ornament that you introduced to
people
but there's this life thing happening
all around you
yeah
and it's got to be exhausting juggling
all that doesn't it
absolutely yeah
i uh i forgot the name of the character
but it's from the movie frozen just let
it go
oh
yeah don't hold it back anymore
let it go
right
cool same team that's cool same team now
you know this you call your parents you
have this conversation it could explode
yeah and think about how freeing it
would be
it would feel great
all right
so either way you win if they welcome
them in they're like great we can
i was going to say something mean
i was going to say that looks so mean
can i say it it was pretty funny
i've heard it all
what if your dad's like oh my gosh we
could share denture cream or what if
that happens that was that's not very
nice joke but it could happen it
probably won't happen but they could get
along great
they probably won't but they could
either way you don't have to carry this
thing anymore you can set it down
fair
and then your parents get to decide
are we willing to lose one of the most
precious and extraordinary women
that we've ever known
because her boyfriend doesn't look like
the picture we had in our head
they get to make that choice
not you
moving forward
consider all the ways that you can
become congruent and have integrity
everywhere
good for you guys four years is a long
time
it's fantastic and i'm glad that you got
friends that are asking you that's
fantastic
um they can bring some humor to the
situation because it's hard it's heavy
and it's different
but at the same time
live free you're worth that you are
worth that we'll be right back
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book i will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the new roads of a well life
moving forward
go to johndaloni.com to get your copy
today that's own your past change your
future at johndaloni.com
all right we are back thanks for
sticking with us this is a tough show
today
i'm glad we get to do this one together
to wrap up
this song they brought from the booth
i've got some funny memories of this
song back in college
it's so fun so great um
but also it to my few buddies who i went
to college with
who are listening to this which they're
probably not listening to this
um they will get a smile but the song is
actually really meaningful and really
deep and really good and it applies to
this show songs by rem it's called
everybody hurts and it goes like this
when the day is long
and the night
is yours alone
when you're sure you've had enough of
this life
well hang on don't let yourself go
because everybody cries and everybody
hurts sometimes
and sometimes everything is wrong
and now it's time to sing along when
your day is night
hold on
if you feel like letting go hold on if
you think you've had too much of this
life hang on
take comfort in your friends
don't throw your hand
if you feel like you're alone you're not
alone
and ladies and gentlemen that's why we
do this show you are not alone we're
here with you we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode i just i
want to be that man that she deserves
and i just i fail miserably
in every step that i try to do anything
this only works
if you you're honest with me
yes sir have you cheated on your wife
i have not
basically it's at the point now where
um it's alternate treatments and it's
terminal yeah i think i'm just finding
myself
not sure how to be there for her i'm
grieving the friendship we had how old
are you
[Music]
um we're both 35. oh my gosh feels like
those who have promised to
help me through this stuff not i don't
mean my wife and my family um but but
counselors and and in the freaking va
okay you named them yeah
i'll name them because it's an atrocity
sometimes the way they treat you guys
after being on the suicide hotline and
all that stuff they canceled two days
beforehand
it feels like
everything is reinforcing the idea that
in this i'm totally alone why struggle
through it anymore and just kind of end
it you know